I defended you
immediately thank you for what what did
I do with the Emmys you know oh oh yeah
first of all I told Jimmy don't go to
the [ __ ] Emmys I told you I've told
you this privately stop posting those
things stop you want to hear it go ahead
yeah okay so originally I'm um I was
supposed to present with Norman Lear
turned 100 years old and we've worked
together but Norman had like 30 birthday
parties and about a week before the
Emmys he says uh you know uh I really
I'll do it if you really need me to I'm
like of course not you know don't worry
about it now Will Arnett and I he's a
good friend of mine are he they asked me
you know will you still do it we need
you to do it so I said okay and um and
I'll do it with Will Arnett so I said
well wouldn't it be funny because I know
we're gonna lose to John Oliver if you
just drag me out there and say I was
upset and I had a few drinks and and I'm
just kind of unconscious and then how I
visualize this happening is he drags me
out
um we read the winner and then I'm just
basically out of the shot and it's not
really a factor but the stage was very
different the stage was like a uh uh
like a catwalk so I I was kind of like
in the in the way which in a way I did
not imagine I I would now some people
read um they read racial stuff into this
and um you know everybody has their own
perspective but the fact of the matter
is I think there were six nominees and
you know this is a plan I had for no
matter who did this no matter what the
shot and now Quinta Brunson happens to
be a friend of mine she gives a speech
we go backstage very happy for her we
talk we have a nice conversation super
happy we have no idea that any anything
is you know anyone is upset or whatever
we have literally no idea and then like
later at the party
we you know learn that people are saying
oh you stole the moment I do understand
that like you know it did it did take
away from
um from especially afterwards because
then she had to answer questions about
that instead of just you know
celebrating her Emmy and then you know I
knew I had her on the show in a couple
of days and I said you know I saw her at
the party and we were talking and I said
well we'll talk about this on the air on
Wednesday and you know because came a
bigger deal in the in the days leading
up to it but you know the idea that
there was any like any ill intent is
ridiculous this is my point about the
Emmys first of all you're trying to do
something funny you know no one is funny
nobody tries anything right exactly and
even this woman uh Quinta they asked her
afterwards she goes oh I wasn't offended
by it but I'll wait and see what the the
well everybody yeah yeah yeah so it's
just it is weird that there are people
who feel that that anyone other than
Quinta was owed an apology for that it's
very it's puzzling to me because you
work for a big Corporation ABC do you
get a call at all we're very we're going
to manage this we have to do no no and
also they just weirdly coincidentally
when I saw the pilot um because I will
see the ABC Pilots before they come out
for right Abbott Elementary I called the
head of ABC I'm like this is a great
show and it's the kind of show you
should be making and then they they also
thought it was great and they intended
to to pick it up but
um and then I reached out to Quentin
this was months before the show
premiered and told her how I felt about
it and so it is it is it is interesting
that it was this particular show right
and I realized like I you know almost
every time I wind up in like a situation
I had it comes totally out of the book
there's no I never know 30 people knew
about that maybe 50 people knew about
this before and nobody was like maybe
you know whatever it's like no it never
occurred to anybody because people know
that it was just a silly thing and not
anything more than that but
um everybody has their own experiences I
guess
foreign